willkommen zur aktuellen sitzung heute
geht es um das gut und böse bei niemand
geringerem als beim anerkannt und in der
letzten sitzung da mag ich natürlich
wieder oben rechts und links für viel
lokales da finden sie noch wo die
aufzeichnung
zur letzten sitzung wie gesagt wo es um
das gute gegen da hatten wir kann es
theoretisch guten behandelt ganz
zentrale theorie weiß ich kann von dem
konsequenz ii allis muss abgrenzte
auffassung dass das gute nur in den
konsequenzen unseren unserer handlung
besteht kann dagegen sagt dass gute
besteht gar nicht in den konsequenzen
einer handlung sei nur im guten willen
der gute wille ist wie ein juwel der
grenzt und die handlung ist wie die
einfassung die umgebung die gemäss hand
nur nebensächlich ist und sie soll nur
den juwel voll zur geltung bringen ist
aber eigentlich nicht wirklich im
zentrum also das ist eben die theorie
von jemand zum guten und jetzt haben ein
paar leitfragen inwiefern ist nach kant
der mensch böse sehen sich wir hatten
diskutiert werde was kann alles böse
sein kann hat eine theorie darüber
inwiefern der mensch böse genannt werden
kann da jetzt aber nicht dieser oder
jener mensch diese person personal
person beere person ca darum geht's dann
nicht wenn er sich die frage stellt ob
der mensch böse ist also er fragte mich
ist dieser mensch böse oder dieser
mensch größe sondern von den menschen
spricht meinte die gattung des menschen
also der mensch als solcher seines pcs
jetzt auch natürlich nicht biologisch
verstanden das wäre natürlich wieder ein
bisschen seltsam da sagt kann gleich was
dazu sagen meint damit letztendlich die
gattung des menschen so verein freies
wesen ist also wir menschen als frei
wesen sind wir böse damit zusammenhängt
auch kann es theorie eines hangs zum
bösen das ist ganz prominente hang zu
lösen müssen auch klären was damit
gemeint ist dann warum kann nach kann
der mensch nicht einen schlechthin bösen
willen besitzen wie ist bei augustinus
möglich war sie an sich noch wir hatten
da diesen birnen diebstahl diskutierter
maria auch wieder oben rechts dann den
link rhein zu dieser sitzung augustinus
sagte wir können
zumindest er kann bei er konnte das böse
um des bösen willen tun vielleicht jetzt
nicht genau um das bösen willen um des
verstoßes gegen das gebot du sollst
nicht stehlen aber wenn man eben ein
anderes gebot gegeben hätte hätte das
vielleicht auch gemacht man muss sich
natürlich fragen hätte er noch hätte er
eventuell einen unschuldigen menschen
getötet nur um des bösen tuns werden
also hier kann man zum beispiel
augustinus die rückfrage stellen ist das
wirklich böse eine birne zu stehlen nur
um sie zu stehlen da kann man doch sagen
ja dann machst du dir doch bequem das
kostet doch keine große gewinnung tun
mal wirklich was böses nun des bösen das
wären die kritische rückfragen
augustinus und dann wird es nämlich
wirklich problematisch wenn man jemanden
verletzt nur beim verletzen möchte da
sehen sie da gibt es dann schon noch ein
unterschied ob ich eine birne stehle nur
weil ich sie stehlen möchte oder ob ich
eine andere person was schaden zufüge
nur weil ich ja schaden zufügen möchte
also das wäre noch mal eine kritische
rückfragen augustinus kann so viel kann
ich schon vorwegnehmen kant verneint das
kann bestreitet dass wir das böse um das
bösen tun tun können oder auch
tatsächlich tun das wäre nach kant
nämlich ein teuflischer wille und sowas
ist nach kant auf den menschen gar nicht
anwendbar ja warum besteht das böse nach
kannten hinten menschlichen neigungen
das ist auch so eine frage man könnte
doch denken böse sind wir deswegen weil
da die neigung mit uns durchgehen und
ziemliche natur unsere betriebe da haben
wir uns nicht alle unter unserer
kontrolle
und dann machen wir irgendetwas böses da
sagt kann so kümmern das böse auch nicht
verstehen das böse liegt nicht darin
dass wir
unkontrolliert emotional sind und so
weiter oder irgendwie triebhaft sind
sondern es hängt immer damit sozusagen
wie wir uns verhalten als es dieser
freiheit aspekt ist bekannt ganz wichtig
dann wie verhalten sich gut und böse
nachbarn zueinander ist auch immer eine
spannende frage die wir im ganzen
seminar behandeln müssen wann immer
diese relation sich anschauen
ist das gute in einem höheren grade sind
als das böse oder sind sie gleich real
ist das böse eine privaten des guten
hier innerlich noch mal an putin habe
ich oben rechts wieder blinkt rein der
hatte diese präventions- theorie
vertreten hatte gesagt das böse ist ein
mangel an sein das böse böse ist
defizitär er hatte von der stars ist es
ist kritisch beraubung gesprochen ist
natürlich die klassische das sind so die
frage jetzt kommen wir zur ersten frage
wie findest der mensch böse der sagt
kann folgendes der satz der mensch ist
böse kann nach dem obigen was er der
frau gesagt nichts anderes sagen wollen
als er ist sich das moralischen gesetzes
bewusst und hat doch die gelegentliche
abweichung von demselben in seine maxime
aufgenommen er ist von natur böse heisst
so viel als dieses gilt hat in seiner
gattung in seiner gattung betrachtet
nicht als ob solche qualität aus einem
gattungsbegriff dem eines menschen
überhaupt könne gefolgert werden denn
als dann wäre sie notwendig sind er kann
nachdem wie man durch erfahrung kennt
der mensch nicht anders beurteilt werden
oder man kann es als subjektive
notwendig in jedem auch den besten
menschen voraussetzen ja also tipp der
beste mensch ist nach kant von natur aus
böse von natur aus böse heißt aber nicht
so böse als ob eine böse biologische
natur hätte aus der man das folgern
könnte so natur meint hier so viel wie
seinem wesen nach der mensch als freies
wesen was hat er gemacht ihr sagt ist
sich das mensch des moralischen gesetz
bewusst und hat doch gelegentlich
abweichung von demselben in seine natur
seine maxime aufgenommen als der mensch
hat und da kommen wir gleich drauf als
mensch den hang zum bösen das anhang
also eine tendenz könnte man auch sagen
nicht direkt das böse um des bösen
willen zu tun so böse ist der mensch von
natur aus nicht nach kann sondern um
immer wieder sich eine ausnahme zu
erlauben also um immer wieder
sich nicht nach dem sittengesetz dem
kategorischen imperativ zu richten
sondern sozusagen ja aber in dieser
situation konnte ich doch ausnahmsweise
mal meine eigenen interessen über die
gesamtinteressen setzt das ist nach kant
dieser hang zum bösen den hat jeder
mensch egal woher kommt egal wie alter
ist egal ob mann oder frau jeder mensch
hat diesen nach kann das ist natürlich
auch einerseits recht ja von kann
spricht ja note sage ich mal weil er
niemanden davon ausnehmen also alle
menschen sind gleich das ist ein
egalitärer begriff des bösen es gibt
keine besseren menschen egal ob sie aus
jetzt so genannten höheren kreisen
stammen ob sie mehr bildung haben oder
weniger bildung ist ein alle gleich das
ist schon mal ziemlich aufklärerisches
gedankengut
wasser hatte in dieser zeit ja jetzt
kann man sich nun fragen was ist der
hang zum bösen der sagt kant da dieser
hang nun selbst als moralisch böse
mithin nicht als natur anlage also nicht
als eine biologische ausstattung sondern
als etwas was die menschen zugerechnet
werden kann betrachtet werden folglich
im gesetzwidrigen maxime der willkür
bestehen muss diese aber der freiheit
wegen für sich als zufällig angesehen
werden müssen welches mit der
allgemeinheit dieses bösen sich wiederum
nicht zusammen rein will wenn ich der
subjektiv oberste grund aller maxime mit
der menschheit selbst sei wodurch es
wolle verwebt und darin gleichsam
gewürze ltte ist so werden wir diesen
einen natürlichen hang zum bösen und
daher doch immer selbst verschuldet sein
muss ihn selbst ein radikales
angeborenes nichtsdestoweniger war von
uns selbst zu gezogenes böse in der
menschlichen natur nennen können das ist
bei kant ziemlich missverständlich
gewesen zb hat goethe johann wolfgang
goethe hat gesagt das sei ja diese alte
gedanke der erbsünde den kant jetzt
wieder hervorkramen sie kennen die
theorie der erbsünde
kann ich auch mal noch ein bisschen
näher was hat sie sagen im handbuch
theorien des bösen finden sie dazu auch
ein kapitel
was auch immer die erbsünde jetzt ist
man darf nach kant nicht das böse so
verstehen als ob wir einfach das böse
geerbt haben weil eben adam und eva vom
baum der erkenntnis gegessen haben und
ihre schuld sozusagen weitergegeben
haben an jede nächste generation so darf
man nach kann nicht das böse sich
vorstellen sondern man muss sich zu
verstellen dass wir es immer schon haben
aber wir haben sonst immer auch schon
aus freiheit zugezogen das löst als wir
sind immer schon wenn man böse sind auch
wenn man von natur aus böse sind aus
eigener schuld boes und das hat sich
jetzt immer die frage hier aber wann
fängt dann diese erste böse tat an bevor
unsere geburt als kleines kind wie kann
man sich das vorstellen
da hat kann eine ganz eigene theorie der
sogenannten intelligent tat das ist nach
kann keine tat keine handlung die in der
welt stattfindet in der welt der
erscheinung sind es ist nach kant eine
tat die unser ganzes wesen ausmacht man
könnte es vielleicht so eine art
grundentscheidung nennen diese
grundentscheidung und das ist verdammt
wichtig die fällt aber nicht in die zeit
das ist keine zeitliche tat das müssen
sie sich vorstellen wie eine
grundorientierung die jeder mensch
einfach als mensch hat man kann es
natürlich auch ein bisschen weiter
erklären zum beispiel mit verweis auf
leibnitz sie erinnern sich noch bei
leibnitz dieses mal um metaphysik mache
ich auch oben rechts sich den linken der
hatte leibnitz davon gesprochen dass
böse beim menschen ist wie eine trägheit
kraft zu verstehen als eine
widerspenstigkeit gegen das gut bereitet
hat er als beispiel dieses schiff im
fluss gebracht dass der strom der das
schiff unseren guten willen mitreisen
möchte aber der wille das schiff weil es
träge ist widersetzt sich erst mit dem
guten so könnte man vielleicht auch
versuchen
ganz theorie zu erklären wichtig ist
hier eben dass wir uns selbst zugezogen
haben wir selbst sind verantwortlich für
unsere böse natur und die natur ist
nichts was wir einfach geerbt haben oder
eine biologische ausstattung durch die
evolutionstheorie ganz wichtig fand die
individuelle freiheit lösen jetzt geht's
zum grund des bösen jetzt kann man sich
natürlich fragen worin besteht jetzt der
grund des bösen kant hat hier gibt es
verschiedene kandidaten für den grund
des bösen man kann sich natürlich immer
auch fragen was ist der grund des guten
was sind die gründe des guten das müssen
wir auch noch ein bisschen in den
nächsten sitzungen diskutieren hat es
gute gründe auf jeden fall ein grund des
guten könnten zum beispiel verschiedene
motivation aale einstellung sein heute
gebe ich noch ein seminar über autos
open house theorie des mitleids als man
könnte zum beispiel sagt ein grund des
guten ist das mitleid dass wir haben
also die motivation die wir haben gegen
die bei einer anderen person man könnte
sagen ein grund des guten ist die
achtung die ich vor der würde eine
person spüren und könnte sagen ein grund
des guten ist die liebe die ich anderen
personen gegenüber
aufbringen das werden auch noch genauer
diskutieren heute geht es um die gründe
des bösen und kann sagt der grund jesus
lösen also der bösen natur die wir uns
selbst aus freiheit zu ziehen der kann
nicht erstens wie man ihnen gemein ich
also gewöhnlich anzugeben flick in der
sinnlichkeit des menschen und den daraus
entspringenden natürliche neigung
umgesetzt werden so könnte man ja denken
aber wir sind ziemlich meinung nach kann
jetzt nicht das was man heute unter sind
nicht versteht diese sexuelle die
sexuelle sinnlichkeit der sinnlichkeit
brief begriff bekannt ist umfassend da
fällt auch das darunter was wir heute
unter sinnlichkeit verstehen aber
sinnlichkeit bedeutet nach kant einfach
nur alles das was wir mit unseren sinnen
wahrnehmen was unsere sinne unsere
wahrnehmung betrifft unsere empirische
warnung betrifft ja also zum beispiel
hunger und so weiter alles was wir
spüren fühlen und was eben ein motiv
werden könnte für unsere handlungen
aufgrund unserer wahrnehmung der
außenwelt
also darin kann der grund des bösen
nicht bestehenden it will neigung denn
nicht allein dass diese neigung keine
gerade beziehung aufs böse haben als sie
sind gar nicht auf diese ebene wie das
böse nach kant vielmehr zu dem was die
moralische gesungen ihrer kraft beweisen
kann zu tugend die gelegenheit geben als
sie können gerade noch ihr zu tugend
anders geben unsere neigung weil wir
nämlich dann die herausforderung haben
es ihnen zu widerstehen sagt kandler die
marken sind nicht an sich böse kann sagt
sogar sie sind eigentlich gut jedenfalls
können wir sie als mittel zum zweck
gebrauchen um ihn zu widerstehen und
dadurch unsere tugend zu stärken ich
gebe mal ein beispiel sie haben zum
beispiel hunger sie möchten jetzt am
liebsten in die mensa und sich ein
doppeltes menü
kaufen und auf der stelle verzieren und
dann denken sie darüber nach über ihre
neigung zu sagen will ich das wirklich
kann ich das wirklich wollen und dann
kommt sie zu dem gedanken nein ich
verhalte mich jetzt mal ganz
diszipliniert zu meiner neigung und
leistete widerstand und dann kann würde
kanzlei in diesem moment werden sie
tugendhafte weil sie ihre neigung
kontrollieren und beherrschen kann also
tugendhat immer auch so ein bisschen was
nach kant mit selbstbeherrschung zu tun
ja
genau also das ist eben das gehört zu
der zu den neigung zu dürfen wir da sein
dass da seine neigung nicht verantworten
wir können es auch nicht weil sie als an
erschaffen und nicht zu urhebern haben
wohl aber den hang zum bösen der in dem
er die moralität des subjekts betrifft
mithin in ihm als einem frei handelnden
wesen angetroffen wird als selbst
verschuldet im bus zugerechnet werden
können ungeachtet der tiefen wurzeln
desselben in die lücke wegen welcher man
sagen muss es sei den menschen von natur
er sei in dem menschen von natur
anzutreffen also für die neigung können
wir nichts erkannt wird die
individuellen individuelle ausstattung
das kann man natürlich noch ein bisschen
näher jetzt betrachten sicherlich kann
man nichts dafür wenn man so erschaffen
ist dass man tendenziell ja jetzt er
hunger auf schokoladeneis hat als auf
äpfel es mag dann gen ethischen grund
geben dass manche menschen vielleicht
lieber süße sachen essen oder die basare
sachen oder lieber und falls nicht
gesunde sachen
und wenn das so der fall wäre dann würde
kann sagen können wir dafür nicht das
kann nicht der grund des bösen sein
natürlich kann man aber dann wieder
sagen aber wir können uns auch gewisse
neigung abtrainieren oder an trainieren
also können wir doch irgendwie was für
die neigung ja jedenfalls meinte jetzt
hier unternehmungen solche neigung die
einfach in uns ganz stark sich bemerkbar
machen für die nichts darin kann der
grund nicht stehen das ist unsere
determinierte natur das ist das
naturgesetz nach kann als diese sachen
bestimmt dafür können wir nichts der
grund des bösen kann aber zweitens
erkannt auch nicht in einer verderbnis
der moralisch gesetzgebenden vernunft
gesetzt werden also kann auch nicht
darin bestehen dass wir eine böse
vernunft haben warum nicht gleich als ob
diese vernunft das ansehen des gesetzes
selbst in sich die fertigen und die
verbindlichkeit aus demselben ab leugnen
können
das ist schlecht schlechterdings
unmöglich sagt kann sich als ein
freihandel des wesen doch von dem einen
von dem einen solchen angemessenen
gesetze dem moralischen entbunden denken
wäre so viel als eine ohne alle gesetze
wirken die ursache denken denn die
bestimmung des nachts naturgesetzen
fällt der freiheit halber weg welches
sich widerspricht also nach kant kann es
auch keine böse vernunft sein warum
nicht weil
eine böse vernunft würde sich selbst
widersprechen die vernunft ist nach
kannte die ursache des guten die
vernunft gibt den kategorischen
imperativ und
deswegen nach kant nicht den grund des
bösen abgeben weil sie nach kant aufs
gute abzielt
und er sagt aber wenn wir dem
moralischen gesetz uns entbunden denken
also gar nicht daran gebunden
so wäre das böse
unabhängig von allen gründen zu denken
und das geht auch nicht also verkannt
muss das böse irgendwas irgendeinen
grund haben der zwischen der moralischen
vernunft liegt und die neigung das ist
der punkt also in den moralischen 50
kann es nicht liegen dass er die
moralische gesetz geben der vernunft
gebietet ja immer nur das gute
und jetzt kommt er zu dem eigentlichen
punkt was der eigentliche grund des
moran spüren ist um als ein grund des
moralisch bösen menschen anzugeben
enthält die sinnlichkeit zu wenig
sinnlichkeit wider die natur die neigung
getriebe denn sie macht den menschen
indem sie die triebfedern die aus der
freiheit entspringen können wegnimmt zu
einem closed irischen
eine vom moralischen gesetz aber frei
sprechend gleichsam boshafte vernunft
ein schlechthin böser wille enthält
dagegen zu viel weil dadurch der
widerstand gegen das gesetz selbst zu
triebfeder denn ohne alle triebfeder
kann die willkür nicht bestimmt werden
oben und so das subjekt einem
teuflischen wesen gemacht werden würde
keines von beiden aber ist auf den
menschen anwendbar also der mensch ist
weder nach kant
böse weil er eine natürliche ausstattung
hat weil dazu sehr hunger verspürt oder
ich weiß nicht was die vitale triebe hat
und er ist auch deswegen nicht böse
sondern weil eine boshafte vernunft hat
man in ihm seine vernunft im sagt tu das
böse
das geht nach hat nicht das wäre ein
teuflisches wesen also der teufel wäre
nach kant offensichtlich anbieten was
eben den widerstreit gegen das gesetz
gegen das sittengesetz selbst zu
triebfeder macht das wäre eben
eigentlich dass das man nur deswegen
handelt weil wir den sittengesetz
zuwiderhandeln möchte und das ist
eigentlich das was augustinus gemacht
hat also war augustinus so kann man
jedenfalls interpretieren nach kant als
er die birne stahl nur um sie zu stehen
einig teuflisch hat er das teuflisches
gemacht das natürlich spannend man würde
es aber sicherlich
bei manchen menschen annehmen dass sie
etwas tolles tool das ist eine riesen
frage die man noch diskutieren muss gibt
es menschen die teufel böses tun die
also wirklich
böse handeln weise böse handeln wollen
weil sie dem oralen gegen handelt wollen
weil sie ganz genau wissen dass das was
sie tun dies ist eine spannende frage ob
so was gibt es wird man nachher noch
diskutieren bekanntester recht
optimistischen seid so was kann es nicht
geben ja kein mensch der wirklich bei
vernunft ist würde sowas tun und dann
wäre die reaktion darauf wenn jemand so
was täten oder vorgeben würde so zu
handeln dass man ihn oder sie für
unzureichend erklärt und sagt er dass
sie ist einfach nicht ganz bei trost
also dass man dann sagt die person ist
einfach psychisch begeistert nicht ganz
zu rechnen war
ja kann man zu rechnen war bei klarem
verstand das böse um das bösen willen
tun kann sagt nein ja
ja jetzt sagte noch was über den hang
zum bösen wenn nun aber gleich dass da
sein diese chance zum bösen in der
menschlichen natur durch erfahrungs
beweise dass in der zeit wirklichen
widerstreit der menschlichen welt gegen
das gesetz da getan werden kann soll
wären uns diese doch nicht eigentliche
beschaffenheit des silben und den grund
dieses wieder streit sind diese weil sie
eine beziehung der freien kür also einer
solchen deren begriff nicht empirisch
ist auf das moralische gesetz als
triebfeder wovon der begriff gleichfalls
rein intellektuell ist betrifft wo es
aus den begriffe des bösen zu fans nach
gesetz der freiheit der verbindlichkeit
der zurechnungsfähigkeit möglich ist bei
apriori erkannt werden das ist wieder so
ein typischer langer satz von kant
also hier sagt jetzt kann das hier in
der zeit also in der erfahrung in dem
was wir erfahren
tatsächlich einen widerstreit der
menschlichen glück für menschliches die
entscheidungsfreiheit
gegen das gesetz erkennen können das
sagt kandler
hier ist jetzt die frage fällt darunter
so was wie augustinus getan hat das
augustinus gegen das sittengesetz
gehandelt hat gegen das gebot um dagegen
zu handeln wäre das dass das kann sagt
das ist jetzt nur diese erfahrung
beweist er aber nichts über unsere
freiheit als solche sagt also dinge
könnte man durchaus in der erfahrung
dass lösung des bösen willen tun in der
erfahrung aber eben nicht in so in einer
art grund maxime in einer ersten maxi
mit dem man sich geben das wäre
natürlich auch nicht ist und sagt gut
wir können ab und zu böse um das bösen
willen handeln aber wir können nicht von
grund auf böse handeln um das böse
mögliches manchmal tun aber unsere
erste maxime unsere erste motivation die
kann so nicht sein naja das ist lässt es
jetzt jedenfalls
jetzt bringt da hier noch mal ein zitat
das genau geht wo man genau augustinus
im hintergrund haben kann er sagt kann
der mensch selbst der ärgste als die
schlimmste böseste jedoch immer tod in
welchem maximen ist auch sei auf das
moralische gesetz nicht gleichsam
rebellischer weise mit aufkündigung des
gehorsams verzichten dieses bringt sich
ihm viel mehr kraft seiner moralischen
anlage unwiderstehlich auf wenn keine
andere triebfeder dagegen wirkte so
würde er auch als hinreichende
bestimmung grund der willkür es in
seinem marco was den aktien aufnehmen
das heißt er würde moralisch gut sein er
der menschheit aber doch auch vermögen
seiner gleichfalls schuldlosen natur
anlage an dem treffen der sinnlichkeit
und nimmt sie nach dem subjektiven
prinzip der selbstliebe auch in seine
maxime auf wenn er diese aber als für
sich an laien hinreichend zur bestimmung
der wilke in seine maxime aufnehmen ohne
sich einst moralische gesetz welches er
doch in sich hat zu kehren so würde er
moralisch spielt ist als der mensch ist
dann böse wenn er dieses gebot der
sitten gesetzes vernimmt in sicht durch
seine fans ja da sagt nämlich kann dass
sich das sittengesetz uns
unwiderstehlich auf bringt also wir
können gar nicht anders als das
sittengesetz erkennen
wir können also nicht direkt gegen das
sittengesetz handel sondern nur so dass
wir
uns versuchen eine ausnahme zu
genehmigen ja dass wir also
die individuellen neigungen über das
sittengesetz ordnen damit man kann nicht
dass wir das sittengesetz
negieren dass man kann nichts dann wenn
wir unsere individuellen interessen über
das sittengesetz ordnet über den
anspruch das sittengesetz dann erkennen
wir ja das sittengesetz gerade dadurch
an überlegen sie mal nennen sie gegen
das sittengesetz handeln indem sie ihre
neigungen vorziehen zum beispiel indem
sie sagen jetzt stelle ich aber halt mal
obwohl es nicht erlaubt es aber meine
individuellen neigungen sind ach so
stark ich will das einfach stehlen ich
will diesen gegenstand haben und stehe
dann wäre das nach kann nicht ein
rebellieren gegen das sittengesetz warum
nicht weil ich würde es ja anerkennt
dass es gilt habe ich würde eben
aufgrund meiner neigungen es machen und
meine neigung wären zb ich will diesen
gegenstand haben dann wäre der grund des
bösen nicht darin zu sehen dass ich um
das bösen willen böse handle sondern
wäre wie im beispiel von augustinus eben
gerade nicht der grund der handlung im
objekt zu sehen also bei augustinus
während dann die birnen die ich wollte
um der birnen willen was er gerade nicht
wollte er wollte sie ja nur deswegen um
sie zu stehen dass der unterschied also
wir handeln danach kann normalerweise
böse dass wir uns von einem gegenstand
angezogen fühlen einen wunsch haben ein
wille bilden und die existenz dieses
gegenstände ist nicht mit dem
sittengesetz oder sagen gebot konform
ist und dann trotzdem uns eine ausnahme
erlauben und dann doch um des
gegenstands will das sittengesetz nicht
beachten das ist was anderes als und des
widerstands gegen des hippen gesetzes
willens handel hat es der entscheidende
unterschied
ja da er nun der mensch natürlicherweise
beide maximen also das sittengesetz und
unsere neigung in die maxim aufnimmt der
auch jede für sich wenn sie allein wäre
zur willens bestimmung hinreichend
finden würde so würde er wenn der
unterschied der maxime bloß auf den
unterschied der triebfedern der materie
der maxime nämlich ob das gesetz oder
singen antrieb eine solche abgeben an
kenne moralisch gut und böse zugleich
sein welches sich nach der einleitung
widerspricht also wir können nach kant
nicht gut und böse zugleich sein wir
können nach kant auch in unseren
handlungen nicht indifferenz sein ja das
ist auch eine option dass er sagt es
gibt handlung die sind weder gut noch
böse nach kant ist jeder hand doch
entweder gut oder böse also war so nah
dran hält man das unentschiedene
handlung gibt es nicht oder genauer
gesagt maximum
wir können nach kant nicht eine gute
maxim und eine böse maxime zugleich in
uns haben das geht so nicht das würde
sich widersprechen als er muss der
unterschied ob der mensch gut oder böse
seien nicht in dem unterschied der
triebfedern der in seine maxime aufnimmt
nicht in ihrer materie soll in der
unterordnung in der form derselben
liegen welche von beiden er zu
bedingungen der anderen macht also die
frage ist ist das sittengesetz ist das
an nummer eins
ordne ich meine entweder interessen im
sittengesetz unter oder ist das in
gesetz nur nummer zwei also orten ich
meine individuelle interessen über das
ist die entscheidende frage und dass man
kann mit der vorn es geht nicht darum
was ich will in meinen neigungen usw
sind es geht darum ob ich in meinem
willen dem sittengesetz die
nummer-eins-position zugestehe ist als
die oberste orientierung meines willens
machen meine handlung oder ob ich mir
ausnahmen erlaubt das ist die
entscheidende frage und das betrifft
nicht die konkreten gegenstände die ich
will das betrifft die form eines wollen
ob ich der sinnlichkeit eben die
priorität gebe oder ob ich sie dem
sittengesetz unterordnen das ist macht
kann die frage danach kann der grund des
bösen das eine schmale ordnung meine
maxime
ja und hier sagt kann dann noch mal was
als der mensch selbst der beste ist nur
dadurch böse dass er die sittliche
ordnung der triebfedern in der
aufstellung derselben in seine maximen
umkehrt
also das ist diese umkehrung also wir
setzen nicht das sittengesetz an nummer
eins sondern unsere nachkommen als
nochmals wir kehren die normale die gute
ordnung um wird es ist so kann man nach
kann das böse beschreiben ist eine
perversion könnte man sagen eine umkehr
der nur perversion eine umkehr der guten
ordnung entscheidend ist dabei aber wie
gesagt dass in der umkehr der guten
ordnung immer noch der sittengesetz
vorhanden ist es wird immer noch
wahrgenommen und auch irgendwie
anerkannt nur eben
mehr als nummer eins und es ist eine
andere situation dagegen gegen das
sittengesetz um das sieht indes um des
verstoßes gegen das sittengesetz will zu
handeln das eine ganz andere sache und
dies laut kant ist für mensch nicht
möglich nur diese perversion worden der
beim triebfeder ja und jetzt kommt eine
ganz interessante beobachtung kann zeigt
nämlich dass es gar nicht so einfach ist
das böse als böses zu erkennen selbst
für uns selbst nicht er sagt bei dieser
umkehrung der triebfedern wenn wir also
das sittengesetz nicht an die nummer
eins stellt sondern nummer zwei durch
seine maxime wieder die sittliche
ordnung können die handlungen dennoch so
gesetzmäßig ausfallen als ob sie aus
echten grundsätzen entsprungen wären das
wieder der punkt den handlungen selbst
können wir eigentlich gar nicht ansehen
ob sie gut oder böse sind nennen sie
nicht gegen irgendwelche gesetze wieder
stoßen wieder wieder stoßen der
verstoßen
kann man ihnen nicht ansehen ob sie
böses im schilde führt wenn sie
gesetzeskonform handeln ich habe da kann
bringt ein beispiel oder man kann das
beispiel weiterführen angenommen ein
kaufmann gibt einem kleinen kind das
konkret korrekte wechselgeld zurück
heraus das kind könnte das geld nicht
nachzählen das wüsste nicht ob der
kaufmann das bedrückt und die eltern
würden es auch nicht herausfinden und
der kaufmann oder die kauffrau gibt das
geld konkret zurück
dann würden die meisten von uns sagen
dann ist er doch gut er oder sie konkret
einem kleinen kind das wechselgeld
zugegeben aber was würde jetzt kann
fragen kann würde sich fragen was war
denn der grund dafür
dass der kaufmann oder kauffrau das
konkrete wächst gilt zugegeben hat ja
also war der grund der dass der kaufmann
angst hatte dass es auf liegt würden sie
dann die handlung noch gut denn wenn er
nur aus angst vor
dem auffliegen seiner bösen intention
des konkrete wechselgeld zugegeben hat
oder war der grund der das ist natürlich
muss ich ein kind das konkret korrekte
wechselgeld herausgeben das doch
selbstverständlich sonst würde ich doch
auch seine würde verletzt ja das würde
ich doch nur instrumentalisieren also
das meint damit kann also wir sehen es
den handlungen nicht an ob sie gut oder
böse sind
er sagte wenn die vernünftige einheit
der maxime überhaupt welche dem
moralischen gesetze algen ist bloss dazu
braucht um die triebfedern der neigung
unter dem namen glückseligkeit einheit
der maxime die in sonst nicht zu kommen
kann hineinzubringen zum beispiel dass
die wahrhaftigkeit wenn man sie zum
grundsatz annehmen uns der ängstlichkeit
überhebt unser lügen die übereinstimmung
zu halten und uns nicht in den schlangen
windungen derselben selbst zu verwickeln
das finde ich eine sehr interessante
wenn du musst mit leider genau eignen da
die empirische karte gut der intel habe
immer noch böse ist ja also es kann sein
dass sie manchmal wahrhaftig handeln
um nicht mehr uns in unseren lügen die
stricke verstricken verstrickungen
aufladen zu müssen ja das könnte ja sein
dass wir angst haben dass unser
lügengebäude aufliegt und dann handeln
wir endlich mal wahrhaftig
das kannst sagen das ist nicht wirklich
gut sondern wir müssen wahrhaftig handel
wegen des gesetzes und nicht damit
unsere lügengespinst nicht auffallen
also kann das sehen sie wiedererkannt
geht es immer um den eigentlichen grund
unseres willens des wollens was die
innere motivation und mich was ist dass
wir es nach außen scheint
ja so kann man das also nennen und kann
spricht dann eben auch von einem
radikalen bösen radikal jetzt nicht wie
ein radikal ist eine radikal ist also
wenn man das radikale böse denkt dann
denkt man gleich da läuft jemand amok
dass man kann gar nicht in das böse sein
kann ist radikal weil es den grund aller
maximen verdirbt denkt sie bei radikal
an dem wort ursprung radix radix heißt
wurzeln sie kennen das alles von
radieschen war dies hier sind kleine
wurzeln und so müssen sich zwischen also
der ursprung hat der grund die wurzel da
kann auch ist es eingewurzelt grund alle
unsere bösen maxxim oder der oberste
grund der urgrund
der ist eben nach kant auch böse wenn
wir böse maxime haben weil aus diesem
grund alle anderen bösen maxime heraus
folgendes eine grundeinstellung wollen
wir uns dem sittengesetz unterordnet
oder nicht und wenn nicht und kann sagt
er wir haben den hang dazu dann folgen
verschiedene böse maxime
das machen wir aber immer aus freiheit
ist auch ganz wichtig nach ganze betont
auch dass radikale böse ist nichts
irgendwie was wir von natur aus
genetisch eingepflanzt bekommen haben
und dann nichts dafür können das ist ja
gerade witz wenn es genetisch
einprogrammiert wäre könnten wir sagen
wir dann kann ich ja gar nix für das
böse ist doch einfach mal die natur
verkannt neigen wir müssen uns dass
besucher stellen das ist zu unserer
natur gehört wir es uns aber selbst
zugezogen haben also eine selbst
zugezogenen natur sozusagen ein bisschen
schwierig sich vorzustellen
wie gesagt an einem anderen zitat das
böse ist die verkehrt haid des herzens
da sieht man wieder diese perversion
also die umkehrung der guten ordnung
und
eben die tendenz nicht dem sich ein
gesetz zu gehorchen das ist nach kannte
grund des bösen da haben wir eben ein
hangar zion das ist einfach in unserer
natur verwurzelt
ja ja sagt auch noch anders dazu dass
diese angeborene schuld
eben immer auf den gebrauch der freiheit
zurück zu finden ist nicht im sinne
einer erbsünde für die man eigentlich
wir individuen gar nichts können sondern
wir selbst sind immer der grund für das
böse das ist ganz wichtig bei krank
immer wieder festzuhalten
ja wir können auch ein bisschen
weitergehen auf dem schein des bösen das
ist auch noch wichtig weil wir nach kant
wie wir gesehen haben ja nie direkt böse
handeln um das böse will sondern wir
handeln so dass wir uns eine ausnahme
erlauben dass wir eben das sittengesetz
nicht an die nummer eins stellen und
jetzt erkannt wie das genau passiert
dass wir nicht dem sittengesetz
folgendes sondern uns eine ausnahme
erlauben deshalb nach ihm was mit dem
schein zu tun mit der selbsttäuschung zu
tun er sagt nämlich diese unredlichkeit
sich selbst blauen dunst vorzumachen
blauen dunst wird machen heißt sich
irgendwelchen illusionen hinzugeben
werde die gründung echte moralische
gesinnung in uns abhält erweitert sich
denn auch brüderlich zur falschheit und
täuschung anderer welche wenn sie nicht
bosheit genannt werden soll doch
wenigstens nichts würdigkeit zu heißen
kathie und liegt in dem radikalen bösen
der menschlichen natur welches indem es
die moralischen urteilskraft in ansehung
dessen wofür man den menschen halten
solle zustimmt und die zurechnung
innerlich und äußerlich ganz ungewiss
macht den faulen fleck unserer gattung
ausmacht der so lange wir eben nicht
herausbringen den keim des guten hindert
sich ja sonst wohl tun zu entwickeln
also sich blauen dunst vormachen dass
wir eine sehr treffende
schilderung bei kant also wir glauben
einfach wir müssten uns nicht am
sittengesetz orientieren wir hätten es
nicht nötig ihm zu folgen und könnten
selbst unsere individuelle interessen an
die nummer eins setzen und deshalb kann
das
das tut den keim des guten wir haben
nämlich in uns auch eine anlage zum
guten einen hand zum bösen aber auch
eine anlage zum guten das
hindert diesen keim sich zu entwickeln
wird also kann ist nicht nur
pessimistisch muss man sagen ja ja
vielen dank für die aufmerksamkeit und
jetzt bin ich gespannt auf die
diskussion dieser doch sehr starken
thesen die kant hier uns vorgeführt